what's up everybody its Warren and today
we have a theory that at first glance
you may not think it's plausible but
when you dive into it and you look at
the facts of the MCU and the logic and
the reasoning behind it it actually
makes a lot of sense
and it could be that the writers and the
directors of previous MCU films
throughout this past 10 years have been
hiding a major easter egg from all of us
in fact we know that James Gunn has said
there is still one easter egg and
guardians of the galaxy that nobody has
figured out yet and could that easter
egg be that star-lord is actually the
grandson of Captain America Steve Rogers
himself so we're going to dive into this
theory and how it makes perfect sense
and how this could be that final missing
Easter egg but real quick I'm giving
away next box 1 or a ps4 to a winner of
my giveaway all you have to do to enter
is be subscribed with notifications
turned on like this video and comment
down below so this theory originally
comes from reddit user chill underscore
bishop and like I said the theory is
that Captain America is the biological
grandfather of quill star-lord and this
theory is based off of the actress Laura
haddock who plays Meredith who was
quills mother now she's in guardians of
the galaxy volume 1 and volume 2 as
quills mother but she's actually in
another MCU film she is in Captain
America the First Avenger in Captain
America the First Avenger when Steve
Rogers is going on tour he goes town to
town city to city and when he gets to
st. Louis he meets a blonde girl who
basically makes his jaw drop this is
Laura haddock the same person that plays
quills mother and Guardians volume 1 and
volume 2 what's also interesting about
this is that every other town that Steve
stops in was displayed on the screen
except for the one where he meets her in
st. Louis so the theory is is that this
is actually quills grandmother and she
ended up getting with Steve Rogers that
night and ended up getting pregnant now
as I mentioned there is a lot to back
this up so stick with me so Captain
America and this woman would have had a
child which would have been Peters
mother then Peter Quill's mother would
go on to eventually have a child with
ego and of course that child is Peter
quill aka star-lord and as we learned
from guardians of the galaxy volume 2
Peter was the only one of egos millions
of kids who had that inner light in him
and if Peter is just a normal person why
didn't he die like all of the other kids
that ego had literally millions of kids
well it's possible that he was able to
survive and have that inner light
because he has some Super Soldier Serum
in him and not only that but the
timeline and the age of the actress
matches up to grandma has Meredith in
the mid 40s when Peter was a young boy
in the late 70s early 80s and the
actress was 32 31 when filming guardians
of the galaxy vol 2 in the scenes where
she meets ego so the timeline lines up
perfectly for this to be true and as
this redditor States Marvel does
everything on purpose with a reason why
would they cast the same actress to play
both of these roles well it is worth
noting that Peters grandmother
Meredith's mother is not in the hospital
when she dies in guardians of the galaxy
vol 1 now Peters grandfather is there
but there is a pretty clear explanation
for this if this theory is true Peters
grandmother got pregnant and she met
another man after she was pregnant or
after she already had the baby this
happens all the time in real life so it
was a perfect explanation but again it
all comes back to the fact that Laura
haddock plays this woman in Captain
America the First Avenger and plays
Meredith quills mother in guardians of
the galaxy 1 & 2 and
star-lord was the only one out of
millions of kids who had that inner
light that ego was looking for and think
about that literally millions of kids
all of different species all of
different ages out of all these millions
of kids quill was the only one who had
that light and could it be due to the
fact that his grandfather was Steve
Rogers Captain America and that he has
Super Soldier Serum in his blood now of
course Marvel could have simply cast
Laura haddock for both of these roles
not thinking anything about it and Peter
simply could just have been that one in
a million
but I definitely think that it would be
insane if Steve Rogers was the
grandfather of Peter quill and as I
mentioned James Gunn said there's still
one Easter egg and guardians of the
galaxy that has not been discovered
perhaps this is it do you think this is
true let me know your thoughts about
this theory in the comments down below
and again don't forget to subscribe and
hit the bell and like this video to
enter my giveaway for a chance to win an
Xbox one or a ps4 as always thank you
all so much for watching we'll forth
you